[Music]
who's ready to go back to Hogwarts we
know we are have you seen the new
fantastic beast trailer the new setting
reveals plenty of things you've never
missed before including a shocking
family tree discovery don't forget to
give this video a thumbs up and
subscribe to the things now let's get to
the video the logo let's start at the
very beginning have you noticed what the
movie got a brand new logo if you
remember the very first fantastic beasts
movie you might know that the Wizarding
World logo wasn't around in the trailer
and it definitely wasn't around in the
actual movie during the intro credits
coincidentally the new logo was launched
on Pottermore just a day before the
second movie trailer was actually
released the logo represents an open
book to give a tribute to the Wizarding
World
literary origins in other words it
represents Harry Potter the books open
pages also represent wands that belong
to the legendary wizards and witches of
the two franchises the bridge aside from
the logo have you noticed where this
Hogwarts story seemed to have picked up
not much is known by the people that
show up at the beginning of the trailer
just yet but focus your attention on the
bridge if you're a huge Harry Potter fan
you probably know that this is the same
bridge that went through quite a lot
during the part two of Deathly Hallows
but it's also the bridge where we've
last seen Harry at Hogwarts as he throws
the Elder Wand across seems very fitting
to pick up right where we left off right
breaking the rules for just a few
seconds into the trailer and one of the
most important Hogwarts rules has
already been broken most fans know about
this because if there's one thing we've
remembered about Hogwarts history is
that you can't operate inside Hogwarts
unless you're Dumbledore or a house-elf
so why is this rule clearly broken did
the director not pay enough attention to
Hermione or was the rule enforced
because of what's about to happen in
this movie either way we can't wait to
see what will go down in this story and
we honestly still can't believe we get
to visit Hogwarts again who are these
people so the people that operate are
supposedly from the Ministry of Magic
and the
to interrogate Dumbledore but other than
that the first movie doesn't really give
us any clues on who they might be
or maybe kind of does pay attention to
the aerial scene of them walking in the
building do you remember seeing the
letter Lestrange when we got to see the
very first cast shots back in November
2017 she was wearing a pink dress and if
you look at the woman walking in the
building you'll see she's also wearing
the pink dress it looks like the
Ministry of Magic isn't happy with
Dumbledore Defense Against the Dark Arts
we get a small glimpse into the defense
against the dark arts classroom we all
know Dumbledore was the professor but
pay attention to the actual classroom
see the desks all shifted to the left
they're the exact same desks the school
used 70 years later for Harry Potter's
version of Hogwarts
we understand desks are expensive but
seriously with all the magic going on in
that room it's a bit surprising these
desks never got any permanent damage but
then again maybe they actually have
their own defense against the art kids
normally leave on classroom desks but
also where is the lady in the pink dress
in that shot the deluminator aha it
feels so good to be back and this takes
us back who doesn't remember Dumbledore
using the deluminator back in the very
first Harry Potter movie and basically
starting off this magical journey
well since Dumbledore is the sole owner
of the deluminator until it's passed on
to Ron it's safe to say it's been
expected to see it again but does this
also mean we'll get to finally learn
more about this magical device and why
it was originally created or will it
forever be a mystery so know about you
but this movie is making us more excited
than the first one location we see news
on the streets of London when he spots
Jude Law on the rooftop just kidding
that's Dumbledore first of all he must
have had a good eyesight second
Dumbledore is just casually standing in
front of the st. Paul's Cathedral clock
the location is also confirmed by the
ec2 sign you see next to the newt which
represents a postcode in London and this
three Kazan is called Cannon Street huh
we love the fact that this location will
probably be added to all Harry Potter
London tours now when did this happen so
it seems like Hogwarts enforced a lot of
new rules during
seventy years and we really wonder why
from the looks of it Dumbledore was the
only professor that ditched the
traditional school robes everyone else
seemed to wear his outfit is spot-on but
then again when did this happen and why
does he always get to wear a snazzy
clothes or those silky robes we see in
the Harry Potter movies and at what
point did he actually decide to ditch
the sharp look and just go full-out silk
we have questions Dumbledore credence
has new powers okay first of all what's
this is that credence isn't he supposed
to have died in the first movie well
apparently not but pay attention to what
he's doing while a maledictis looking
which is next to him if you need a
reminder a maledictis is a person that
can turn into a beast as they have a
cursed blood a fan theory that
maledictis is actually Nagini
is already going around is cretins able
to control his powers now and only use
his hand this is pretty epic are the two
working together
what's the dark stuff it looks pretty
cool and we can't wait to see what's
going to happen between these two the
family tree one of the biggest mysteries
this trailer has is the strange wall
that someone we're assuming it's
Dumbledore stands in front of but if you
look closely you'll notice he's actually
looking at the strangest family tree and
if you look even closer you'll notice
that the names could read Corvis with
strange at the top and if you really
zoom in you'll see something that
resembles the name credence on the right
and led up on the left
wait what these two are related and
Creedence isn't Lestrange
well that just brings a whole nother
mystery into the mix seriously we have a
feeling this movie's going to blow our
mind and we can't wait to see it
JK Rowling was right Hogwarts will
always be there to welcome us home and
that's all for our video don't forget to
subscribe to the things and tell us how
you felt about this video thanks for
watching see you next time
[Music]